I think that the shift from symmetry to
asymmetry in warfare is a major
transformational force I think that the
rise of China and not simply
quantitatively the rise of China but
trying to understand and predict today
how China will exercise what China's
soft powers will be and how the exercise
of soft powers in the world to envision
China having a big military big economy
simply big is a story that has been told
already and by now people in power
should have dealt with that it will
always be bigger but trying to really
understand how a Chinese way of thinking
will have softer influences on the way
we think about things the way we
interact with each other I think is sort
of the central question right now is
what will try to contribute to the world
through its rise China has been lacking
for confidence for many many many years
and now is struggling with that
confidence that necessarily has to come
with economic strength and military
strength and so forth and how it uses
that and how it kind of achieves its
goals of a harmonious society well at
the same time becoming a world player is
something that I'm particularly
interested in and if you think about
sort of one weak signal there being the
sort of new ties between China and
Africa I think is really really
interesting stuff China is using science
as a geopolitical tool for example
that's kind of
interesting and so creating scientific
ties between their researchers and other
researchers in different parts of the
world before at the nation state level
there is an official you know
geopolitical time and so exporting
science is sort of a fascinating 21st
century notion of diplomacy that china
is experimenting with the values of
society in China I think is so I think
this is a central you know so a global
theme I think that I think that we are
starting to reach the point where
climate change has achieved acceptance
as a global issue it's on the agenda it
is fodder for presidential candidates
you need to have a policy it's achieved
the kind of acceptance as an issue I
think that many have also achieved a
great deal in introducing it as
something of importance to all factors
of sigh fast society from you know
evangelical Christians to moms to world
leaders to CEOs of companies who see
green as as an engine for economic
growth and ebitda so I think it's
achieved the kind of widespread
penetration in society very effectively
in the last couple of years and so I
think this is now recutting climate
change is now reached a point where it
is quite simply I think about the next
president of the United States and
whether or not that next president has
the courage and vision to advance you
know the policy the the speech I think
this is as much about oratory as it is
about action I mean it's of course about
action but it is also that laying out
what it means to be sort of an energy in
the pen
and nation and I think that we're not
going to see you know China take the
steps it should take it must take
without the United States taking the
steps it must take and it should take
and so I think this is simply but very
importantly about elekton the right
leader democrat or republican who very
much recognizes the importance of the
issue has a clear strategy and can
restore us leadership in this incredibly
important you know global topic so i
think that i think that's where that
needs to go and i think if i was to pick
out maybe one other kind of weak signal
um i think it would i think it would
most certainly be the incorporation of
science into larger or more obviously
large ministries and sort of decisions
that need to be made by leaders as
happening out with regularity and
science is a cornerstone of the agenda
the World Economic Forum now leaders see
their science advisors and science
ministers as important and as having a
relationship with national security and
economic policy and so forth and so I
think that the incorporation of science
into the decision-making apparatus of
leaders globally is taking place in very
many parts of the world in very
different ways but it's sort of an
important weak signal I think right
you